was the 2023 local elections two reasons
why this really matters first of all
obviously if you live in one of the 230
areas in England where there are local
elections you get to decide your local
representative but secondly this is the
biggest electoral test the biggest
moment that we're going to have ahead of
the next general election so it gives us
a sense of where we may be heading so
what is the big picture here well this
is the kind of map of these elections so
these are the areas that are the
councils that are being contested at
this time around it's not everywhere
it's just England and it's only these
230 that we're looking at here not
indeed Wales uh or Scotland we do have
some Northern Irish local elections
coming up in a couple of weeks but this
is what happened last time around in
2019 it primarily actually conservative
councilors uh that are kind of these are
conservative dominated areas so they're
in the lead uh at the moment so the
question is what's going to happen to
These Bars is that blue bar going to go
down that's what the polls suggest and
the Red Bar go up same thing again for
councils
um but a good night for Kirsten would
involve pushing that up potentially by
about 400 uh six maybe even more but
there is something he's fighting against
this is a bit of History here this is
going all the way back to the 1990s and
it's showing you the Share of counselors
for each of the major parties and look
at this trend so in 1991 the labor party
became the biggest party of local
government then it took until 1997 for
Tony Blair to win that Landslide
election same thing for the conservative
party 2003 and then it wasn't until 2010
that they won that election or indeed
came in first place but for the labor
party right now at least before these
local elections they're still in second
place so kirst armor will be hoping to
get that red line above the blue line
but no other leader of the labor party
will do the conservative party have been
able to turn that into an instant
general election wins so a bit of an
issue uh facing him there as is what's
happening in places like the teas Valley
so remember to talk about the red wall
different parts that used to be labor
heartlands which the conservatives did
better in well here's the tease Valley
here look you can see it's dark gray
that means no overall control
not long ago a few years ago that was
all red so the tismali was all red and
you can see if you look at Middlesbrough
what's happened here that labor sharer
of the vote falling falling falling
conservatives could have more or less
you know doing kind of pretty resilient
but it's the labor vote that's been
falling similar thing across most of the
teas Valley all of those labor shares
the votes in many of those areas going
down and down and down so Kirsten will
be hoping to get those lines going up
again that of course is not the only
story but the rebel one big thing then
you've got the question of how the lib
Downs are going to do the green party
the conservatives of course as a whole
as well there'll be many data points
many bits of analysis we'll be bringing
you through the night and indeed into
the next day